hemos definido explícitamente cuatro
sucesiones distintas y lo que quiero que
pienses es si estas sucesiones convergen
o divergen y tienes que recordar que una
sucesión converge eso significa que si n
es muy muy muy grande se va haciendo muy
muy grande el valor de la sucesión se
aproxima a algún valor y que la
asociación diverge significa pues que no
se aproxima no pero no se aproxima a
ningún valor alguno ok entonces te
invito a que hagas una pausa y
reflexiones qué ocurre con estas cuatro
sucesiones
entonces para poder trabajar con ellas
lo que vamos a tratar de ver es por
ejemplo qué pasa con con el grado de los
de los polinomios que aparecen en la
primera entonces si nosotros
desarrollamos tenemos n por en es n
cuadrada y luego tenemos 8 por n y una
por n entonces eso nos da 9 n + 8 por 1
que es 8 y todo esto va dividido todo
esto va dividido entre n por n menos 10
que es n cuadrada menos 10 n entonces
pensemos en lo siguiente cuando la n es
muy muy muy pero muy grande n cuadrada
es el término dominante del numerador
aunque aquí aparece una n en realidad
pues está esta expresión es lineal y no
crece tan rápido como n cuadrada así que
para él es muy grandes esta es la que
nos va a importar lo mismo va a pasar
para el término para el polinomio de
abajo verdad n cuadrada es la que va a
dominar y podríamos pensar que esto es n
cuadrada entre n
para em es muy pero muy grandes ok eso
eso se hace esencialmente uno y por lo
tanto podemos podemos casi apostar que
esto converge muy bien por supuesto digo
casi porque necesitaríamos una prueba
pero no lo voy a hacer rigurosamente en
este vídeo solo es tratar de identificar
cuando convergen o cuando no muy bien
vamos con el pse el segundo ejemplo y
ahora aquí pensemos cuál es el término
que crece más rápido en esta sucesión
entonces aquí tenemos un exponencial un
exponencial
este exponencial e elevado a la n eso
crece muy rápido verdad si recordamos la
gráfica es algo que crece así
verdad ahí está el 1 donde cruz en fin
y mientras tanto abajo tenemos una
expresión lineal una expresión lineal
que eso más o menos se ve como algo así
entonces queda claro que para en es muy
grande es el numerador en este caso
crece muchísimo así que vamos a quitar
todo esto y lo que podemos decir es que
este término crece mucho más rápido
mucho más rápido
rápido que el término dominante de acá
abajo que es por n muy bien entonces
como éste crece muy muy rápido más que
éste esto se va a infinito entonces
diverge diverge muy bien vamos a ver qué
pasa con el siguiente caso en el
siguiente caso el término n cuadrada es
el dominante es el que se va más rápido
mientras que está dividido entre n así
que esto claramente va a bueno se va a
ir a infinito diverge muy bien por qué
pues porque el numerador crece mucho más
rápido que el denominador ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa con el último ejemplo
tenemos menos 1 a la n tiene vale 1 o
bueno tiene vale 0 es menos 1 a la 0 es
1 tiene vale 1 tenemos menos 1 a la 1
que es menos 1 tiene vale 2 es menos 1
al cuadrado que es uno si n vale 3 es 1
por menos bueno sería menos 1 al cubo
que es menos 1 x menos 1 x menos uno que
es
- 1 y así sucesivamente va a ir
oscilando entre 1 y menos 1 entonces
aunque esta sucesión es acotada es decir
este no se no crece demasiado ni decrece
tanto siempre se mantiene muy fijo
verdad entre dos valores nada más
entonces esta sucesión es acotada sin
embargo no no no se no tiene algún valor
fijo de hecho siempre va a ir oscilando
entre 1 y menos 1 así que de esta forma
podemos decir que la sucesión divergen